was da zum beispiel in russischen
talkshows aktuell gesagt wird da wird
ganz offen jahr gedroht mit atomraketen
mit atomwaffen die man richtung europa
schickt richtung london richtung paris
richtung berlin schauen wir einmal in
das was da so verbreitet wird also immer
wieder raketen rhetorik und dann die
entsprechenden bilder eine demonstration
der macht dort wird dann ganz offen
darüber gestritten in diesen shows wie
lange man wohl braucht bis die raketen
dann berlin getroffen haben oder eben
paris getroffen haben man zeigt
entsprechende grafiken und dann wird
eben gehetzt richtung europa dort wird
dann ausgerechnet wieviel sekunden das
dauern könnte also keine vier minuten
und zack als berlin oder paris oder
london getroffen also das ist diese
rhetorik aktuell das heißt herr patzelt
diese ängste die ja die haben durchaus
eine berechtigung das ist ernst zu
nehmen was dort gesagt wird in diesen
schrei talkshows sagen wir so es sind
ganz klare einschüchterungsversuche wir
kennen das schon aus der debatte um die
nato nachrüstung anfang der 1980 er
jahre als die russische propaganda mit
ihren deutschen mit gläubigern das ganze
oder großen teil des landes hat glauben
machen dass wenn die nato die
nachrüstung vollzieht der dritte
weltkrieg unausweichlich ist denn das
könnten die russen niemals mit sich
machen lassen dass der westen statt
klein beizugeben nachrüstet das ist im
grunde das gleiche dass wir derzeit
wieder sehen man sieht auch dass diese
abschreckung gut funktioniert in
deutschland folgt man sich mehr um einen
atomkrieg als um die freiheit und das
überleben der ukraine die richtige
haltung angesichts solcher drohungen
wäre genau die den frieden kalten krieg
gesichert hat man sagt freunde ihr könnt
uns ton aber unsere raketen sind auch
nicht langsamer als der euro muss csa
ist genau so verletzlich wie berlin
verletzlich ist also macht mal halblang
das sind ganz wahnsinnige
kriegsszenarien im übrigen das sei noch
angefügt ist einem jeden der sich ein
wenig militärisch auskennt klar dass
seit jeher die russische militär planung
die militärdoktrin davon ausgeht dass
auf dem gefechtsfeld taktische
atomwaffen eingesetzt werden deswegen
ist dann notwendig ist sozusagen das zu
haben was man immer genannt hat die
eskalation dominanz um vor diesen
einsatz taktischer nuklearwaffen
abzuschrecken heran es ist das bei uns
kulturell so dass wir jetzt nicht dazu
neigen großartige drohungen richtung
moskau zu schicken aber wenn so was
kommt dort in den talkshows so sind
natürlich ganz genau so vom
außenminister von den
kabinettsmitgliedern von putin wäre es
dann jetzt nicht strategisch viel
sinnvoller wir würden genau solche
drohungen zurück schicken und sagen im
moment mal also wir richten jetzt erst
recht unserer
atomraketen richtung moskau richtung
russland
also wenn der eine das macht auf diese
art und weise wie wir es gerade gehört
haben das ist ja blanke propaganda organ
da die angewendet wird beispielsweise um
den versuch der zu anfang des krieges
gescheitert war nämlich europa oder auch
die nato zu spalten wenn wir das mit den
gleichen methoden
beantworten begeben uns im prinzip auf
das niveau vor der russin ich sage mal
ganz einfach das muss nicht sein wir
sind recht starten wir können vernünftig
damit umgehen wir gehen schüler damit um
vielleicht man muss sich darüber im
klaren sein dass dieses tatsächlich ich
sage mal propaganda ist die die menschen
einschüchtern soll und wenn wir
entsprechend reagieren oder genauso
reagieren dann ist damit anteile erfolgt
aber erreicht worden vielleicht erreicht
worden wenn wir uns einschüchtern lassen
oder genau das passiert doch aktuell wir
schauen mal rauf auf ein zitat von
viktor jerofejew
schriftsteller in russland der schickt
eine normalere drohung richtung westen
richtung europa richtung deutschland der
droht ganz aktuell damit dass man doch
eine atomwaffe in die ostsee eine
atomrakete in der ostsee zünden könnte
also ihr deutschen seid euch vor es
könnte schrecklich werden für euch sagt
er das hören doch wir in deutschland
herr patzelt und ja ergebnis wir lassen
uns einschüchtern oder stimmt das nicht
es haben sich viele auf den weg zur
freiwilligen einschüchterung selbst
einschüchterung gemacht an dieser stelle
ist es hilfreich sich an einem berühmten
satz eines amerikanischen präsidenten zu
kriegszeiten erinnern wenn ich mich
nicht falsch erinnere sei es teddy
roosevelt der gesagt hat sprich sanft
habe aber immer einen dicken stock dabei
jetzt zu sagen wir sind da nicht schutz
und hilflos wenn man uns schaden will
könnte mir auch schaden ist keine
kriegsrhetorik es ist ein verweis darauf
dass auch wir einen dicken stock haben
und dass wir es uns deswegen leisten
können sanft zu sprechen diplomatie
hängt immer davon ab dass man das
potenzial hat sich nicht erpressen zu
lassen und solange der russische
präsident glaubt er könne uns erpressen
und einschüchtern kann man in aller
freundlichkeit sagen dann zu einseitig
werden die gewichte auf dieser welt auch
nicht verteilt drums warum kehren wir in
diesen momenten wo solche drogen
ausgesprochen werden nicht zur alten
kalten kriegs rhetorik zur alten
strategie der abschreckung ganz offen
zurück
die strategie der abschreckung besteht
nach wie vor da gibt es überhaupt keinen
zweifel dran die usa sind dafür soll ich
mal die unterstützende macht und die
garantie machte deutschland beteiligen
uns ja auch über die nukleare teilhabe
von da hat sich daran nichts geändert
aber ich würde aussagen die sie dort
getroffen worden sind von putin abwärts
auf noch von leuten die sich
entsprechend organist auskennen zwar
nicht unterbewerten da wahrlich
überbewerten und ich muss nicht sogleich
ein rhetorik greifen um eine
entsprechende rücken zu erzielen die
ohnehin das möchte ich auch hinweisen
aber der musste der russischen
bevölkerung nicht angekommen wird herr
müller was ist wenn solche szenarien zu
treffen also mann droht ganz offen damit
und dann immer zu sagen passiert ja doch
nicht passiert ja doch nicht damit haben
wir in den letzten wochen nicht so ganz
großen erfolg gehabt das heißt wenn so
was zutrifft gilt dann das versprechen
von ihrem kanzler heute abend noch
einmal erneuert dass deutschland auf
keinen fall kriegspartei wird ja wir tun
alles auch abgestimmt mit dem partner
mit frankreich mit italien und
großbritannien mit den usa tun wir alles
und das zu verhindern dass dieser krieg
sich aus atom mafia in der ostsee staune
darüber wie man wenn man solche bilder
sieht und wenn man solche sätze hört aus
russland wie man dann ganz sorglos
darüber hinweg geben kann nein man muss
so rieger haben aber ohne sich durch von
angst lähmen zu lassen trotzdem
entschieden auftreten aber eben
sorgenvoll und besonnen auch abwägen was
man tun kann und genau das findet statt
es ist ja nicht so dass es in den
letzten acht wochen keine unterstützung
für die ukraine gegeben hat von allen
europäischen partnern hat es die gegeben
auch von deutschland in
unterschiedlichster form aber wir tun
das in einer form abgestimmt auch mit
den usa wo wir die ukraine helfen können
ohne dass das weit über die ukraine
hinaus es kalt in nimmt der putin das
ist doch eine wichtige frage uns ernst
wenn wir so demokratisch abwägen und so
diskutiere hieß die un sowie der russe
schluss oder nimmt er uns nicht ernst es
ist in diesen fragen immer wichtig dass
ein schleier das nicht genau bescheid
wissen was alles passieren kann über der
sache liegt wenn man dem politischen und
im fall der ukraine nach kriegerischen
gegner mitteilt du kannst tun wirst du
willst auf keinen fall werden wir uns
einmischen außer einer beihilfe mit
waffen in den konflikt dann ist es
nachgerade eine einladung aus zu testen
wie weit man denn gehen könnte es wäre
besser gewesen nicht immer klar
auszuschließen was alles auf keinen fall
geschehen wird sondern auf hinzuweisen
es könnte auch etwas geschehen folglich
lieber freund aus moskau zwei
vorsichtiger aber passiert nicht genau
das heraus gerade wir sagen immer was
wir auf keinen fall wollen und wir
teilen das ja hier alle in der runde wir
wollen auf keinen fall eine eskalation
des krieges aber wenn wir all das dieses
signal immer nach moskau schicken dann
sagt herr patzelt dann macht er halt was
er will mit uns der führt uns an der
nase rum
dieser fehler ist ja nicht im netz nach
wochen entstanden sondern diesen fehler
ist vor 20 jahren entstanden weil wir
gut ihn immer haben machen lassen
stichwort gehorchen krieg stichwort
alexion der krim und dergleichen mehr
und wir sind jetzt an einer stelle wo
ein tatsächlicher krieg in der ukraine
geführt wird wo ihr halt eben nicht mehr
nachgeben dürfen aber wir wollen ja von
unserer seite her auch nicht zu schlagen
das ja nicht unsere absicht dass die
indirekte hilfe die wir haben die
ukraine leisten damit die ukraine in der
lage ist sich gegen russland gegen die
russische organisation zu verteidigen
ist ja schon ein völlig anderes signal
dass die signale die wir vor zwanzig
über letzten 20 jahren gesendet habe von
daher kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen
auch mit den worten des kanzlers auf der
einen seite die sache ernst zu nehmen
die ängste ernst zu nehmen die die
bevölkerung hat und mit denjenigen die
ja nicht durch deutschland vorgegeben
worden sind so waren beispielsweise
durch die nato mit diesen linien weiter
fortzufahren und keinen zentimeter mehr
zurückzuweichen aber entscheidend
herbert jansky ist doch nicht ob wir das
hier alle ernst nehmen sondern ob der
mann im kreml das ernst nimmt also ab
der das als situationen oder als
position der stärke wertet was im moment
europa was die westliche welt tut was
der kanzler heute abend sagt
ja ganz genau man muss auch verstehen
und man darf sich wirklich nicht testen
lassen und einschüchtern lassen weil
innerhalb seines welt modell handelt
putin ja rational so für ja so verstören
diese kommentare auch sind und das ganze
hätte die wir jetzt aus moskau sehen
trotzdem er hat sich dieses ziel gesetzt
das gros russische reich wieder neu zu
erstellen und das verfolgte auch aber
muss bedenken der hat ja riesige
probleme militärische probleme in der
ukraine und deswegen könnte er sich
jetzt keinen offenen mit den tierischen
konflikt mit der nato erlauben aber hier
ist christus schüchtern lassen herbert
jansky haben wir uns in deutschland
einschüchtern lassen sitzt er wladimir
putin jetzt möglicherweise dort in
russland am vorabend seiner parade und
lacht über das was der kanzler am abend
gesagt hat ich weiß es nicht ob er lacht
aber er hat ganz klar das ziel weniger
in dem interventionen von europa
richtung ukraine zu bekommen er will
europa und die nato generell
einschüchtern damit die ukraine weniger
unterstützt wird und dieses ziel
verfolgt er ganz genau mit dieser
einrichtung mit dieser hitze und die
herrschaften stück weit ihr eindruck aus
kiew hat er das geschafft sie waren auch
viele tage ihr während des krieges in
deutschland sind wir eingeschüchtert
worden
ich glaube er hat es zum teil geschafft
ich kann nicht sagen das ist jetzt ein
riesenerfolg für ihn ist aber natürlich
hat er einen teilerfolg schon herum und
er hat es ja auch geschafft eine gewisse
verzögerung einzuführen mindestens weil
deutschland hat ja ganz lange gezögert
überlegt ob jetzt mehr waffen geliefert
werden sollen oder nicht und das kann
man sich schon als einen erfolg deuten
turismo der patzelt sind wir deswegen so
zögerlich gewesen ist der kanzler so
zögerlich gewesen weil man ihm genau
abwägt könnte den das stören im kreml
möglicherweise könnte der sich auf den
schlips getreten fühlen könnte der sich
provoziert fühlen es ist nicht verkehrt
nicht zu provozieren
es ist richtig auf mögliche
berührungspunkte gemeinsame interessen
auszugehen kein öl ins feuer zu gießen
das problem das wir haben und dessen
folgen wir sehen liegt viel tiefer es
hat sich die deutsche politische
führungsschicht und ein großer teil der
deutschen lange zeit falsche
vorstellungen von der beschaffenheit von
großmachtpolitik gemacht es waren viele
in deutschland wirklich der festen
ansicht dass man durch handel wandel
erzeugen kann es waren viele der ansicht
dass wenn man selbst friedfertig ist
friedfertigkeit in der welt ausbrechen
würde es waren viele der ansicht dass
man frieden mit möglichst wenig
eigentlich immer weniger waffen schaffen
kann deswegen ja auch die bundeswehr im
wesentlichen der sparbüchse genutzt
haben und jetzt ganz drastisch
unzulängliche streitkräfte haben das
sind die grundprobleme da müssen die
deutschen mit sich selbst zurechtkommen
und das eben jetzt in diese
kriegssituation will noch einmal auf die
rhetorik zu sprechen kommen herr general
die rhetorik der vergangenheit wie
gesagt das war völlig unnötig und das
haben wir alle auch damals schon
kulturell nicht gemocht aber wenn da
eine drohung aus moskau gekommen wäre
dann hätte man gesagt genau und wenn du
eine atomwaffe schickst dann schicken
wir 100 in deine richtung und dann bist
du erledigt diese rhetorik gibt es heute
nicht mehr ist das gut so oder können
sie sagen doch klar wir haben die
atomsprengköpfe weiterhin auf russland
auf moskau gerichtet
also es bedarf der rhetorik nicht um die
abschreckung trotzdem von der restlichen
sollte er auf zur aufrecht zu erhalten
das muss man deutlich sagen mit dem
säbel rasseln erreicht man
möglicherweise weniger als wenn man den
säbel zieht aber erst noch gestillt und
das mit der phase befinden wir uns
gerade vielleicht nur zwei anmerkungen
ganz kurz franz ich möchte noch einmal
nachfragen ist der säbel denn überhaupt
vorhanden also sprich sind die
atomwaffen in bereitschaft sind die
richtung moskau richtung russland
gerichtet
ich antworte mit einem eindeutigen ja
die entsprechenden planungsprozesse
laufen auch im westen um die atomwaffen
sind vorhanden und sind in einem relativ
guten status
wir sehen heute weil wir gerade über
einschüchterungen gesprochen haben habe
ich trotzdem noch mal ein haken
unbedingt
ich habe in der vergangenen woche den
letzten tagen habe ich einen
präsidenten gesehen von belarus der was
gesagt hat zu dem thema von einsatz von
atome
er war bisher der tollste vasall und der
treuste
folge von putin und er hat sich gegen
den einsatz von atomwaffen aller
deutlichkeit ausgesprochen weil er
dadurch nachteile für sein eigenes land
befürchtet erste aussage zweite aussage
den augen etwas weiter stand ein
bisschen weg vom militärischen es gibt
da noch erlernen in fernen osten der als
ziel ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass
der einsatz von russischen atomwaffen
mit blick auf seine welt macht politik
oder weltpolitik auch nicht sooo
wunderbar in den kram passen würde von
daher kann ich mir vorstellen dass diese
beiden versuchen werden auf den einfluss
zu nehmen ob ihnen das gelingt ich denke
an die worte von arroganz gehen die ja
gerade gesagt hat putin hat sich sein
eigenes weltbild zurechtgezimmert und
bereut ihr in der lage sind dieses
weltbild zu erschüttern das solle fragen
die kann ich nicht beantworten und die
macht die sache mit blick auf die
beobachtung seiner reaktion
ausgesprochen schwierig herr patzelt ist
der eindruck dass unser abschreckung
ankommt im kreml dass der glaubt dass
wir bereit sind im notfall selbst
atomwaffen einzusetzen das wird er nicht
austesten wollen weil die risiken
einfach zu groß sind aber dass wir
entschlossen sind nicht einfach zusehen
bei dem was er jetzt in der ukraine
veranstaltet das hat er begriffen seit
dem moment wo die bundesrepublik
deutschland bereit war auch schweres
gerät auf panzer zu liefern das ist ein
signal dass zu spät gekommen ist aber es
ist gekommen und das ist das wesentliche
würden sie diesen satz aussprechen herr
müller als sozialdemokrat wenn er damit
anfängt wenn er atomwaffen einsetzt dann
werden wir unsere beziehungsweise die
amerikanischen einsetzen um gottes
willen was für eine diskussion wird hier
gerade geführt der general hat es gerade
zu recht gesagt es ist manchmal auch
klug zu wissen was der andere tun kann
ohne dass man ständig damit droht wenn
wir jetzt hier im ernst auch im rahmen
dieses gesprächs durchspielen wie ein
atomkrieg aussieht das ist es doch ganz
furchtbar wir müssen doch sehen dass ihr
unterhalb dieser eskalation alles tun um
der ukraine zu helfen und diesen
konflikt diese militärischen konflikt so
schnell wie möglich zu beenden darum
geht es und der wird nicht das ist 100
prozentig sicher ausschließlich mit
militärischen mitteln entschieden werden
sondern wir müssen neben der stärke
neben der auch bereitschaft die die
ukraine zeigt und die wir unterstützen
wollen immer auch einen diplomatischen
weg suchen um diesen konflikt zu beenden
dass die die immer nur mehr waffen
fordern das sind in aller regel die die
nicht verantwortung tragen und auch
nicht darüber entscheiden müssen wie wir
mit diesen konflikt umgehen es ist
aufgabe eines kanzlers genau abzuwägen
wie er diesen konflikt wie er dort mit
sich einmischt wie weit er gehen kann
und was er für das eigene land auch tun
muss dafür ist er gewählt dass seine
aufgabe als bundeskanzler und das macht
olaf scholz hervorragend lasst uns hier
keine unnützen fronten aufbauen es geht
nicht um die frage sollen wir mit atomen
schlägen ton oder nicht dann sollte ich
das mal werden es geht einfach darum zu
zeigen dass der westen bereit ist die
ukraine auch in einem abnutzungskrieg
mit weiteren militärischen kräften
unterstützen russland kommt allmählich
an die grenze der erneuerbar kite seiner
verloren gegangene kriegs güter allein
schon die aussicht dass der westen noch
ziemlich lange wird liefern können
russland aber nicht wird deeskalierend
wirken folglich müssen wir jetzt nicht
über atom krise reden wenn sie sollten
aber schon klar machen dass wir nicht
hilflos sind wir müssen keine angst
haben vor russischen atom- schlägen denn
soviel weiß selbst ein nicht ganz
rational handelnde russische
staatspräsident das im zweifelsfall die
nato im mehr schaden kann als er der
nato